How do we determine how a campaign is doing or why is it not doing well?
So on the screen here I brought up this is a this is a good one to look at because this is one where
Nick has a good website that's ranking well and SEO wise it's bringing in enough leads so we've
we've kind of supplemented with a little bit of ad spend during the colder months
and so I want to show you what the numbers that we're seeing here so you can kind of get an idea
of what to look at so your your the answer to the question is going to be in the data
so in the data here what I like to do is I like to pull up where my keywords are
you can also pull this up in in the ads and the assets I like to look at what keywords are landing
where they're landing and you can see here you know this this ad itself has had three total
conversions it's had a little bit more than that but we're going to we're going to look at those
ones that got they got tagged what they're getting tagged for we're looking at the total
impressions here the big thing I'm looking for here is that am I getting impressions
and am I getting a CTR which is the click through rate so in general about five you know four to
four to six percent is considered decent and and you're doing a good job above that is is a really
good job there's people that make millions of dollars a year selling at two to three percent
CTR okay so a lot of it is just about volume but for us for our purposes if you're hitting in the
above six percent on the CTR you're probably doing something good the other the other way to
look at this too is another way to look at it is this search impression rate and if you go to
columns if you don't have that on yours you can go to modify columns here you go to the competitive
metrics right here and you'll see that top left search impression share and then you click apply
and that brings that column up for you and so if this search if this search impression share is
in the higher range or above 50 you're doing really really well and what you can do is you
can use that data if I'm not getting the impressions that I want then I need to look at my my daily
budget and what I'm bidding cpc wise and that's the first place to look the second place to look
is where my CTR is my CTR is in the four percent range then I need to understand why typically
that's going to be a budget issue and or possibly an ad copy issue but if your budget looks good and
the cpc looks good if you go back and look at google google keyword planner and and that is
where it needs to be then I would look at my ad copy next and then after that we look at
search impression share and that tells us how we're doing to our competitors and then we have
the conversion rate after that the conversion rate I'm not too worried about because most of
you are not setting up the conversion tag so it's something you don't really need to worry about
right now but that those are the things that I look at if my impressions are good I have good CTR
I'm doing favorable with the search impression share now I start looking at my landing page
only then do I start looking at my landing page after I've checked my ad copy is my ad
copyright is my ad copy landing for the search terms that I want for the services I'm providing
and you know there's everything working does the number work on it and all those things
and then you want now you want to go start addressing your landing page issue